what's the deal with airplane
peanuts Comics comic is a term a lot of
comedians use to describe some of their
peers right here we go let's get into my
guest today he's a Comics comic every
comic respects this guy he is a
comedian's comedian he really is a
one-of-a-kind act he's a very funny
comedian he's a comic's comic I say this
again please watch it a true comic's
comic but what does that phrase really
mean for some it's the ultimate honor
and a nod to their ability to make even
the world's best comedians cackle with
laughter but the phrase itself can
sometimes feel like a double-edged sword
carrying the negative connotation that
these Comics are underachieving in some
way given their tremendous level of
talent it's common to hear this title
thrown around for guys like davel Brian
Holtzman and even Patrice O'Neal but
when you ask a few of the biggest
comedians in the industry a different
name comes to mind Lou cats may not be a
name you've heard much of yet but most
comedians certainly have unfortunately
there's a long history of elite joke
writers who receive the utmost respect
and admiration from their peers but
never seem to Garner that same level of
notoriety on the public level and until
recently there was very little you could
do as a comedian in those shoes with all
the typical industry gatekeeping and
limited television spots it's almost
always been impossible to take control
of your own career but with the rise in
popularity of YouTube specials online
standup clips and the comedy business as
a whole new avenues have begun to emerge
for comedians to expand their careers
completely on their own and after
titling his latest hour special the Best
comedian you've never heard of Lou Katz
is a great example Lou you're often
called a Comics comic we hear that term
a lot in the comedy industry but what
does that term mean to you a funny guy
who can't sell tickets that's what it
means to me but no it's a it's a it's a
compliment if you know Comics are the
toughest judge comedians see the most
comedy you know and uh and I do feel
like my peers respect me and enjoy my
work and that means the world to me that
they that they they dig my stuff well
speaking of your peers here that goes
perfectly into our next question David
tells called you one of the best joke
writers working today Alli Wong says
you're one of the funniest and most
prolific comedians she's ever known and
with such high praise from alltime
greats in your industry along with your
obvious comedic Talent how do you think
you became as you said quote the Best
comedian we've never heard of by a uh a
refusal to to really do the social media
thing until like last year I think I
kind of I was on there for a while I got
in like one minor argument with somebody
and I was like I'm I don't want to do
that and it was a huge mistake I've
watched people just pass me by cuz
they're just they're playing the game I
didn't want to play it and I'm finally
kind of playing the game and it's
already working out great you know I
still don't have a podcast but the
YouTube special is doing great and I'm
posting on on uh on the other socials
clips and stuff and and it seems to be
catching on I'm just old enough that
it's like uh hard for me to do social
media it's not like just a natural thing
and not that not that it's excuse
there's plenty of people my age and
older who have managed to rank you know
deal with it and and blow up from it but
it just it's been tough for me I believe
in things like privacy and a lack of
Shame well speaking of getting involved
into this new age in the social media
realm you have multiple half hours on
Comedy Central and you've released
standup albums but a month ago was your
first YouTube special what was the
decision making process that led you to
YouTube have you enjoyed releasing your
content this way overall getting
involved in this world as you're saying
and do you think the releasing of
independent specials can help bring more
talent to the public eye that's great
questions um there's a few of them there
let me try and get them all well first
of all the choice to go to YouTube was
really centered on the fact that Netflix
said no so that meant uh YouTube was the
place to go uh I've been excited to go
on there and honestly in uh in
retrospect I don't think the special
would have worked on Netflix I didn't
realize it because it's the theme of the
special is all very organic that's this
is really things that I'm going through
but the fact that it's on YouTube I
think actually works for it it makes
sense yes I'm I'm talking a little bit
about my struggle and it's on YouTube so
that you know kind of makes sense that
it's on there and I think it's great
that everyone's doing their own special
that we all have access that being said
I don't know if comedians can just keep
spending all of our money for very
little return year after year I don't I
don't what's the end game for me instead
of making like you know six figures for
these specials is what people were
making we are now losing like tens of
thousands of dollars I don't know how we
can how long that can go on but I'm I'm
very happy for the opportunity and and
the and the feedback has been amazing
you know you you hear that um YouTube is
just full of like uh U and honestly like
I talk like I wasn't on social media
that much YouTube I was probably the
least active on of all everything on
social you know I was doing shorts but I
wasn't really posting on there that much
and I had like very few subscribers
before this and you hear that the
comments are going to be horrible don't
read the comments they're going to be
horrible and I'll tell you they've been
they've been like 95% just very kind and
people seem to really like it so it's
been really amazing to get that instant
feedback that I wouldn't have gotten on
any other platform where I'm just seeing
people comment as they watch it and they
mostly they're showing me a lot of love
so that feels great and I guess the end
game just thinking about it after after
you said that I you know you spend all
this money to make a special would the
best return be to just gather a bunch of
fans that will make that money back on
the road I guess it's a little too early
for you cuz it's only been a month to
see how that's changed but have you
noticed uh at just gigs around in your
normal career people coming up more of a
pop since the special uh yeah I mean yes
it's definitely the way the way the idea
is that you make the money back through
ticket sales so um you know I haven't
been able to notice it yet um and if you
think about it it's like I need all
these people to be in one city in every
city so even I've gotten I've gotten
like I'm I'm I'm coming up on 400,000
views which is like by any measure of
success on YouTube whether I don't know
where those people are you I don't and I
don't and I need them all to be in
certain cities on certain nights so it's
a little hard to make happen but that
being said the cool thing is I'm
instantly noticing it uh I haven't done
my own weekend yet I'll be in the creek
and the cave uh in December and that's
when I'll I guess I'll kind of see but I
just went out with a tell and like man a
lot of people had had seen the special
already which was very cool and even you
know it's also cool is you said Comics
comic I've been on the road so much for
the last 6 months I've barely been at
the seller in New York I went through
last night and a bunch of the other
Comics are like they they're noticing
you know what I mean so it's definitely
made that impact where people have
noticed it and uh and so we'll see you
know it's it's going to take a while to
see how it um if it really affects
ticket sales yeah that's very exciting
so you're in New York right now uh New
York guy right now you've been a part of
both the New York and the LA comedy
scenes though it's in San Francisco
Where is the biggest difference between
the two oh wow well I mean New York is
really centered on and this is New York
La I won't talk about the Bay Area
because that's that's where I started
but that's a long time ago and it's
still like it's still LA and New York
are the two Battle of the big a cities
it's that La New York is really focused
on standup that's what it's about and La
is is also for people that want to work
in all those other parts of the
entertainment industry so I used to say
that like La you can't deny that there's
very famous very funny comics living in
La New York has the best comedian you've
never heard of and and now that's
started to change because there's people
in New York who' kind of blown up but
there's still a lot of people who are so
good and you like wow that guy's amazing
I never heard like still there's people
that that haven't that I know around the
scene that are like that I mean you can
tell when you ask a comedian so if you
ask a a comedian in New York like what
they're up to what's going on they're
going to tell you about their road work
you ask a comedian in La what's going on
they're going to tell you about the
other projects that they're working on
they don't necessarily work the road and
I'm like they are very funny comics in
LA but it's like also you know you talk
to an LA comic half the time they're
like yeah I haven't been on stage in
like four months I'm like what are you
are you a you're but you're a comic I
mean whatever you say I don't know you
know uh because they're usually running
these other projects and because the
stage time in LA is typically not that
good you know unfortunately I'm going to
be spending more time out there because
um my family's out there I need to help
them out them out a little bit and
honestly I'm nervous about this stage
time you know I'm luckily I'm still
going to keep my place in in New York
and be able to come back here and work
out but I don't know man it's it's
there's less stage time and the quality
is is not as good there's something
about the audiences out there I don't
know man hon say this is going to sound
crazy because I'm from LA and I started
in San Francisco but I have trouble with
a West Coast audience a lot of the time
uh they're they can be a little bit
weird man they're a little they're a
little uptight to be honest you're kind
of an old school guy what do you think
about what's going on in Austin right
now kind of becoming a third City I mean
I love I love all these other scenes
coming up it's always to me I'm so I'm
so old school that it just shocks me
that these smaller towns and Austin's a
good siiz city but can can I I I don't I
I'm still can't wrap my mind around how
much comedy people want to consume in
this in the world right now it's it was
so not popular when I started that I
still don't really understand like wow
the amount of tickets that are selling
everywhere is crazy you know I don't
know how long Austin can really support
all these clubs and all the things I
mean at the same time are there enough
people there is it enough of a tourist
destination to do that I've been to the
Mothership it's a very beautiful Club
you know I think that's uh it's really
cool but also there I feel like I love
it but there there needs to be more
bigger Comics coming there they they
don't they need a deeper bench is what I
would say you know either they got to
bring up the some of the locals or some
bigger people need to move there cuz you
look at it and there's like there's
great Comics but it seems to be like the
same few Comics every week when unless
there's a big guest coming through and a
lot of times there are but I just think
to run a showcase show where there's
local I mean man people love Joe Rogan
and they'll see Joe Rogan every night of
the week and I and I guess I guess he
can sustain it but it would be cool if
it became you know truly like these
other cities anying out of the week
you're seeing like six Headliners you
know which would be great and right now
it's mostly you know it's it's Brian
Simpson it's Tony hinchcliff it's it's
Joe Rogan and it's Ron White and
hopefully Tom or Christina are in town
too you know what I mean those like the
fact that I can name the comics who are
going to be there at any given night you
know so I I think it's a beautiful Club
I think he's done a lot to really make
it a a Comics comedy club and I just
wish the the the bench was deeper and
and more comics will move out there
those Comics I mentioned amazing comics
and you could see them any night did I
mention Ron and Ron White's there you
know like those are those are great
Comics to see all the time but it would
be cool if there was even uh a larger
community of comics to support that club
is what I would say that's so true great
starting five and then they just need to
fill out the rest of the roster that
that makes a lot of sense uh there's so
many different comedians of we've kind
of talked about different shapes and
sizes Styles and quite honestly a bunch
of different levels of talent when it's
all said and done at the end of the day
what factors do you think elevates some
comedians into that next next level of
Fame to me it's I mean it's clicking
with an audience somehow I don't really
know how clearly I don't know how that
works or I I would made my special about
what it is but I I don't know it's it's
clicking with an audience uh in some
kind of way and I don't know I never
know what it is you know I can't say I
never know what it is there's certain
Comics who like I think of it I know you
have this uh Sports uh uh analogy of the
whole show is based on but for me I used
to think that there's comics where where
man if if I I if ID invested in this
stock I would be like a a millionaire by
now and like I like I knew it with Nate
barazi I knew it you know I knew it with
Ali Wong like those are my my friends
and also I knew it I saw them and I
would have put a ton of money in them
and and I knew they would blow up and
there's other people that I'm surprised
they haven't blown up as much yet Mike
veon who's finally like kind of got a
pop this year through Nate through
putting out his special on YouTube but I
saw him and he was like one of these
comics when I moved here he was exactly
what I'm talking about him and Nate were
these Comics that like I'd never heard
of them and they blew my mind coming
from LA and I just think Von's so funny
and yet he hasn't totally popped yet
maybe he has now with his new special
with that that came out this year which
got like over a million views so happy
for him but there's still Comics that
I'm like this person is great and yet I
they're not they're not getting uh the
amount of love that I I think they
deserve and the other thing is that you
have to realize that um as much as we
want to have control and agency over our
careers we don't a lot of it's just luck
and sometimes it works out and sometimes
it doesn't and all we can do is really
keep producing quality work but a lot of
it's just luck all right last question
for you here is it true that when you
were 9 years old you used to write jokes
and send them to the The Tonight Show
and that Johnny Carson actually read two
of them on air and do you remember the
jokes uh yes this is this is totally
true uh uh but it's it's a little bit I
didn't it's not like I wrote jokes they
um you know I grew up in Los Angeles and
so the Tonight Show would uh they would
like go to a local elementary school and
give them like prompts like questions
and then they would kind of we' just
answer the questions and then it was
like kids do the darnest things and they
would read the lines out so it's not
like I'm just submitting jokes like I
gotta make it on the it's not it's not
like that it's not like that at all I
just I just answer these question
questions and other kids did too and
they all got them on air but none of
them became professional comedians so
it's more an interesting factor for my
life and actually you know I found the
footage the other day of him reading the
jokes and I'm going to upload it shortly
so it's going to be on social media soon
sent out some questionnaires from third
grade to the sixth grade that would be
about 8 to I guess what 11 years old
something like that mhm you are a father
turkey what will you say to your wife
and kids the day before Thanksgiving as
the father
turkey I know here's what I love lisis
cats okay
here are all your lion
costumes not bad Lis cat if you were a
turkey what would you say to keep from
getting cooked I'll mail you a check for
a million
dollars thank you so much for your time
today any upcoming shows any social
medias that you want to plug uh anything
at all that the people should know yeah
please uh check out the special if you
haven't it's on my channel Lou cats
comedy if you have checked it out pass
along to friends and I'd love for you
guys come out and see me I'm doing all
different jokes that are on the special
so if even if you seen this special come
see me live it's going to be totally
different um I'll be in Austin in the
middle of December at the creek in the
cave and then in January I'm going to be
in a Sacramento at the punchline there
and then also at the Irvine Improv for
one night only at the Irvine Improv so
look at those dates you can check them
out our website Lou cats.com but those
are my upcoming Club dates that I'm
doing and uh yeah come out and see me
it's all new jokes because Louie was
generous enough to come on our show for
an interview I think it would be fun to
see if our community of Comedy fans fans
watching this video can actively Spike
his special in YouTube's algorithm if
you want to be part of this experiment
go to Lou cat's channel right after this
and leave a comment on the Best comedian
you've never heard of who knows maybe
joke Road subscribers can tack on
another few thousand views for the
Ultimate Comics
comic joke
world that's did it joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
world check it out